やあ！
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
男子なら誰もが憧れる…
とも限りませんが
なんかこうロマンを感じる人が多いと思います
車！
僕もずっとこの
トヨタの８６って車をずっと乗ってるんですけども
カッコいいんですよね。中見ますか？
なんかこういう車ね
女子ウケが良くないって聞いたことがあるんですけど
もう僕が良かったらそれでいいかなと思って
８６にさせていただきました！
で、ここにもこういう羽がついていたり
上にサメみたいなのがあったり
本当は車の色、赤が良かったんですけども
真っ赤とか目立つと思って
車の中を赤にしました
汚くて申し訳ないんですけども
こんなのが僕の車でございます
この車は大学生の時に買って
もう結構３年ぐらい乗ってるんですよ
この車に３年乗って。あの正直に言いましょう
飽きました
車自体が飽きたというか
色に飽きてしまいました
結構走ってまして
東京とか…わー。すげーヘリ飛ぶなあ
うるせえ！
僕けっこうこの車じつは乗ってまして
静岡から東京行くときとか結構これで
一人でビュンビュンって行ってたりしたので
走行距離が結構いってるので
そろそろ買い替え時かなとか思いつつも
けどまだ乗りたいっていう気持ちがあるけど
色に飽きてしまった
ていうことは、することは一つ！
車のカラーリングを変えてみようかなと思いまして
そもそも目立たないようにしてたんですけども
こういう風に堂々と車もバレてるので
もう逆に目立っちゃっていいんじゃないかな
ということで
このカラーリングのついた黒から別の色に
変えようと思います
このことはまだ誰にも言ってないので
ワンチャンちょっとドッキリっぽく出来るかなと
思いつつ、さっそく車の色を変えてくれる工場に
行こうと思います。では行こう！
うわ！いつの間に！
知らぬ間にダメージを負ってた
あ、本当ですか
なんか色とかって、何色にできたりします？
基本的には存在する車の色だったら
なるほどなるほど
おすすめとかって…？笑
やるなら奇抜な色にしたいんですよね
黒に飽きたので何かしらになれたらと思って
明るい色？
明るい感じがいいですね
できればすごい色にしたいよねえ
わーすげえ。ありがとうございます。
トヨタで言うと
すごいこんなに…
これまだ全然一部
トヨタだけなので
すげー
というわけでちょっといろいろ話し合った結果
一応、色は決まったので
この色に車を塗り替えていこうと思います
では、完成をお楽しみに！
よろしくお願いいたします。
さよなら８６…
僕の８６を修理に出してから
はや２週間がたちました
一応連絡を受けて、もう完成したっていうことなので
さっそく車屋さんに向かってきました
え、めっちゃ気になる
まだ見たことないんだよね
クールな俺の真っ黒な８６は
どうなっているのでしょうか
その真相に迫ります
おはようございます！
うーわ！すげー
こちらです
すげー！
でもかっこいいですね
もっとかわいらしいデザインになるかと思ったら
けっこうキマってるぞこれ
黒とのコントラストがかっこいいというか。
かっこいい×３
かっこいいですね
待って待って待ってやばいやばい
かっこいい！
うぉー
部分的に黒なのですごい引き締まって見えますよね
待って、あれ？かっこいいなあ
目立つ？
目立ちますこれは
傷が無くなってる！
バンパーの傷とかも一応全部拾えるだけ
拾って直しておきました
ありがとうございます。
雨降ったらだんだん黒になっていったら
嫌だなって思いました
車を買い替えるとかだったら普通にあるんですけど
色がこんなことになるのは
多分想像つかないと思うので
今からいろんな人に
いい意味で変わり果てたこの８６の姿を見せて
驚かせていきたいと思います
ではとりあえず家に帰ります
ありがとうございました！
では帰ります
え？なんやなんや
え？え？ピンクや！
待って！かっこよ！
どうするんですかこれ本当に笑
なんかここ最近見ないって思いませんでした？
そう！なんかね最近ないなって話してたんですよ
これ触れちゃいけないなって話してて
こういうことだったのか笑
８６ちゃんの色、変えてみました
え、これ完全な…
もう完全なもう…
業者に頼んで、これです、もう。
これでいくの？
これでいきます